with all these new fractional ownership
companies all these new offerings
with the injection of private equity
into the hobby i've heard you say
150 million or is being deployed into
the hobby by this group maybe 50 million
there
20 million there whatever it is you know
you alluded to it earlier but
based on what we're seeing at the high
end of the hobby
what do you think the impact of those
new models are going to be on the hobby
long term oh i think it's going to be
great and by the way
good for rally for you know for uh for
them to uh
buy the card long term that's not a
million dollar card
long term that's a five 10 million auto
card i mean you're talking about a
pop two you're not talking about jordan
pop 300
yeah that sold for 738 you're talking
about a pop two so
if they hang on to that card they're
gonna make a lot of money uh with the
card but what do i think about what
they're gonna be doing i think they'll
be bullying a little bit i think there's
a little bit of manipulation going on i
think there's a little bit of
uh bullying going on because they can
you know there's no
the hearings for wall street bets
and gamestop just started this week like
they don't even know what the hell
they're gonna do with reddit and what
are you going to do with these wall
street
guys with 8.2 million people that are on
there saying
let's go get you know gang stop and
screw these
you know melvin capital or seth cohen
guys and you know
the citroen the hell with them and then
boom you know melvin capital
loses you know some say half a billion
some say three billion
to the point where seth cohen had to
come in and him and a couple partners
you know bail them out with 2.75 billion
dollars why
because the small guys teamed up and
said let's go against the big
guy so but for the longest time the big
guys could manipulate
the longest time that's how they make
their money and if those guys are not
getting into the cart industry you have
to know that they're going to manipulate
for example
if you own 50 of the jordan psa 10's
86 flier and say it's a 200 000 card
why wouldn't i buy that card at an
auction at six hundred thousand dollars
seven hundred thousand dollars i don't
care if i lost five hundred thousand
dollars
now everybody in the market is writing
50 different articles in a day saying
the jordan's really worth 700 it's going
to a million
we own 50 of them let's lose one at 700
000.
so that's 500 000 loss but we got 49
that we're going to make
500 on we just made 10 million bucks so
the ability
to for the math wizards to come in and
manipulate is very high
i don't see this industry being
regulated anytime soon i don't see it
being regulated
you know like when i say anytime soon i
mean i don't see being regulated maybe
never maybe
not during you and i being alive so 10
20 30 years so
what does that do uh it kind of gets the
cards
away from the emotion goes away
it becomes logical now it's more logical
now it's no longer emotion that's no
longer childlike now it's more
hey i'm going to buy and i'm going to
make it's more the
you know the the hedge fund mentality
the stack of fund mentality which i'm in
that world i'm a guy that's a series 766
so i know
the wiring of running the business and
saying i still gotta profit from it
but uh i think uh you know
you know what else is gonna come in when
that takes place
you know um sometimes it takes the fun
out of the game
uh because something that is supposed to
only be worth 50k
now it's 300k it's not a 300 000 card
but they've been able to make it a three
hundred thousand dollar card because
they're the market maker
but it's a fifty thousand dollar card so
a person that wanted to buy that card
for 50 they can't
but they don't want to buy the card
because they want to flip it they want
to buy the card because they want to own
it
and appreciate the card for a few years
and tell the story to their kids so
a little bit of that's gonna go away um
but i also don't see this being you know
like oh my gosh you know
jordan's card gonna go straight to 3
million and 5 million at 10 million
listen 86 fleer
jordan last dance comes out
738 and it's a pop 300
the math just doesn't make any sense for
it to be
a pop 300 738 000 card
in today's economy so somebody's going
to play this video and says you were
wrong
yeah maybe five years from now 10 years
from now i'm saying in today's economy
but
never forget the basic rule of warren
buffett it's a very basic rule of warren
buffett
when everyone's greedy be fearful
when everyone's fearful be greedy a lot
of the stuff i buy
i buy when people are afraid like what
the moment
covet took place first 30 days of kobe i
bought a few hundred thousand dollars
worth of cards
i just went out there and i said hey
cash man people are scared right now i'm
not what do you need boom boom boom boom
boom but today i'm a lit i just bought a
nice card i just bought
um uh a uh uh
whatever just by zion williamson
national treasure
three out of five you'd say you know
a 350 000 card i just bought in the last
couple weeks
why there's only five of them uh uh
uh you know obviously the big one still
hasn't come out what's gonna happen to
zion the next couple years it's a risk
that 350 could be a million in the next
six 12 18 months
or that 350 could be 200 and i'm gonna
have to sit on it for the next five
years which i'm pretty patient but i'm
good either way
so there are still opportunities out
there to
you know hedge your investments but
it's a different game today it's a very
very different game today people have to
be a little bit more
not saying the word optimistic a little
bit more
calculating and strategic today rather
than just winging it today
yeah you know we've seen the market just
the overall
the index if the indices if you will
really skyrocket in the last
12 months let's say the growth rate
has been extraordinary and i don't
believe the growth rate is sustainable
and i don't think anybody thinks the
growth rate is sustainable for much
longer but
what what i'm a what i want to ask you
is
once the growth rate plateaus once the
values plateau
do you think that those new higher
values are sustainable or do you see any
sort of
retraction what do you see happening so
so i could be very wrong with this i
could be very very wrong with this and
i'm okay with that
i've been wrong many times in my life my
goal is to be right 51
of the time as long as that's the
percentage i'm trying to increase it
from 51 and up now i can't go to 100
but you know i want to be up there in
the 70s and 80s this is this is my
um uh uh
you know opinion on this okay
if you buy a 1951
or 52 willie mays long
term you're gonna lose a psa eight no
if you buy a pete rose card rookie
psa seven psa eight you're gonna lose
long term
no is he gonna eventually be in the hall
of fame yes
will it be when he's alive i don't know
so you have to know like with
investments as a financial advisor would
sit with the client
and you would sit down with the client
and you typically ask him three
different questions so you have a few
different questions so it's okay
when it comes down to your investments
you have three different buckets short
term
midterm long term right okay what's
short term emergency fund money market
anything that's liquid
zero to 12 months okay great cool so
what do you have in your short term
i advise you that six to 12 months
depending on what your lifestyle is
i like 12 to 24 months but at least you
want to have six to 12 months of your
expenses say so if your expense are 10
grand a month
i want to see you have 60 20 000 in cash
savings
okay we have it phenomenal what's
midterm midterm is 12
to 10 years this could be i'm planning
for
my daughter's wedding she's 27 and in
our tradition we have to pay for it and
she's been with this guy for five years
he proposed i think it's coming up i
have to be ready to spend a hundred
thousand dollars
great you know your armenian your
whatever your let's write that down okay
great
you know midterm uh we are thinking
about buying a bigger house okay just
okay great we mid-term we'd like to get
some mutual funds that's going to okay
great
then you go long-term what's long-term
what do you have in the long term i have
401k i have a
defined benefit i have pension i have
this i have social
okay long-term is what 10 on 10 20
30 whatever your age is 40.
so you go on am i going to lose
long term with pre-70s cards
no way am i going to lose
long-term with these new sexy four five
hundred thousand dollar cards
absolutely i could absolutely i could
long term so for me you know
i understand us getting excited about
some of the players today i get it i
mean i bought you know
million dollars worth of cards for
today's players but i know it's
it's okay so when you buy a mutual fund
you got three different types of mutual
funds you've got small cap mid cap large
caps small cap of small companies mid
cap as large companies large campus
larger companies right so what's a large
cap okay
uh microsoft facebook walmart those are
large cap okay
if today amazon's worth say two trillion
dollars
how long is it gonna take to their worth
four trillion dollars one year
i don't think so two years three years i
don't know
four trillion so if i put a hundred
thousand when is it going to be 200
000 maybe seven years twelve percent
rate of return okay cool
i'm still good with that but it's not
like it's going to double three four
five times now if i invested a small cap
company
you know like for example clubhouse the
new app just came out called clubhouse
everybody's doing their you know podcast
there right okay
clubhouse just raised a hundred million
dollars
and 100 million dollars they just raised
at a valuation of a billion dollars so
the company's worth 900 they put 100
million dollars that's a billion dollar
company
clubhouse is blowing up that's a small
cap company
and what if you put a hundred thousand
dollars in there with a billion dollar
company and that company is a 50 billion
auto company come
five years from now your hundred
thousand is all of a sudden five million
bucks that's pretty cool so
all the new stuff i consider small cap
all the you know the psa jordan large
cap you'll find uh
the wayne gretzky to whoever that bought
those two cars i knew what i was selling
they're fine a
bill russell rookie card you know your
fi any of that stuff
you're fine uh and then you know you're
kind of playing the risk game what kind
of risk tolerance do you have if you
don't have a lot of risk tolerance don't
play with today's money
if you have scholars if you are more
safe conservative go bank on the stuff
that is bankable
some of the stuff today is too risky
yeah okay fair stuff man i appreciate it
okay i want a couple more questions i
want to get in before you have to go
the first one when we talk about the
market and you just addressed it but i
want to know if you're
current on these uh these sort of uh
debates if you will between garyvee and
vegas dave i know you're familiar with
these guys
uh do you have a take on on what their
their sort of opposing views right now
what is their opposing views i'm curious
vegas dave says in
18 to 24 months the market's going to
crash like nothing we've ever seen
before
and garyvee says we're just at the
beginning
yeah i i uh okay so i agree with both of
them
but here's what my argument is for both
i do think the market's gonna crash
but how long is it gonna be a permanent
one
absolutely not listen listen
i'm talking to clients about deploy
a small percentage of your money into
cards
you know people are like okay i'm gonna
put one percent of my money into
bitcoin fine cool you got a million
bucks
you want to put 10 grand in bitcoin go
for it one to five percent
do it go for it okay what percentage
should i put into
precious metals i think you should
consider putting
two to five percent of your money in
precious metals gold
who buys gold what is gold about gold
is about armageddon whoever is buying
gold
is project predicting what a massive
market crash let's not
let's not confuse the two joe but it
doesn't mean it's gonna happen
you're buying because you're hedging is
why you're buying precious metals right
so
cards uh are they gonna go the way
they've gone the last 12 months
absolutely not in a 12-month period
absolutely not zero so why what do you
mean by this okay
so go and think about what dramatically
changed
in the last 24 months dramatically
changed
in the last 24 months so if you go back
and you think about the first ever
national debate on tv by presidents
that was on tv that changed the game was
between nixon and kennedy
prior to that it was only radio nixon
was ridiculous on radio
terrible on tv the first time they did
the debate on tv
he didn't shave he hadn't he didn't look
good
he was didn't get the right amount of
sleep he looked terrible he was sweating
they didn't do makeup on him
the night before kennedy went to a
tanning bed
he did his tanning he did his makeup he
shaved he got 10 hours of sleep
camera turns on kennedy looks
presidential nixon doesn't look
presidential
the game officially changed on how you
pick a president it was voiced before
now it's voice and face and you know
what it is you know what's happened last
12 years with high pitched presidents
twitter and social media the obama era
the trump era
right it's a completely different game
okay so what's dramatically changed the
last 12 to
24 months that caused cards to blow up
private equity guys got it and now you
can buy shares
of staff cards you don't buy the whole
card you buy shares of cards
that's a dramatic event that we're
talking about
so gary's right in the fact that
something just happened that changed the
game
yes but dave is also right because
48 000 to 738 in 12 months absolutely
not that's not sustainable
you you think a 738 is gonna you know
okay
set 738 on 48 is what if you think about
738 uh uh on 48
it's 15 times okay you know you know
what it is
if we take 7 38 times 15 times it's an
11 million auto car do you think the
jordan pop 300 car is going to be 11
million dollar car
it's not okay so what happened the last
12 months
never going to happen again the next
time it happens is because something
another weird event took place that's
technologically advanced
and we have to be prepared for that the
date comes so i
what i'm hearing you say is the growth
is unsustainable which the growth rate
is unsustainable i completely agree with
that
but are you saying then that you think
that jordan for 738 thousand dollars is
going to
come down in value significantly over
the next
couple years 100 percent yes here's why
okay so i went to a rolex store today i
want to buy my my wife a rolex it's her
birthday tomorrow she's born on
valentine's day okay
and she's 21 weeks pregnant and it's our
fourth one and it's not like she's under
27 a baby or 30s
she's turning 42. okay it was a risk
when we got pregnant it was supposed to
be twins we lost one of them
and one of them made it and we're
expecting a baby
so i went i'm like let me buy you a
watch and would you have not a watch
person baby
let's look at a watchful okay babe this
is the only one i like i'm like oh my
gosh like this
doesn't like jewelry doesn't like
diamonds then like it's a blessing don't
get me wrong
you know but but at the same time it's
like i want to buy you something nice
so i go to the rolex door let me tell
you
four rows i can't even show you like i
have four rows
okay like this where you can have
watches in this place
you know how many watches that there was
at least
200 spots of shown watches
that they could put there you know how
many they had three of them they only
had three watches to sell
zero for men it was three watches that
they had it was a datejust
28 that one was a chocolate face one was
a silver face and another was a you know
another face that they had
i said what's going on here she says
well
first of all rolex was shut down for two
months because of covet
then you have covet but then you have
people that are not traveling they're
staying home which means what
they have more money so guess what
people are doing what they're buying a
ton of stuff
we have to be real and realize
there's a lot of fake money right now
when there's a lot of fake money there's
fake
valuations right now okay billionaires
are
flocking over to florida every house i
make an offer
on somebody comes in i'm not a
billionaire so if i make an offer on a
house for 18 and a half million dollars
the next day guy comes in hey cash offer
24 billion
my realtor finally said you're dealing
with billionaires buddy and you're not
in the billionaire community so guess
what if you're making these kinds of
offers
either make a real offer this is not the
right time to negotiate it's the worst
time to negotiate
so you you get when you're looking at
and then like right now if you want to
buy a
daytona platinum rolex watch okay if you
want to buy daytona platinum rolex watch
by the way jeremy we can go 20 more
if you want to buy daytona platinum
rolex watch okay
a daytona platinum rolex watch right now
good luck finding one
good luck finding one it's a hundred
thousand dollars you can't find one
today
why can't you find one because everybody
has cash right now
people think last year oh my gosh market
crash market didn't crash last year
look i'm not trying to scare people here
but there's very easy indicators to look
at to know that the market is crashing
so forget about cards for a second
forget about cards for a second
set cards aside set cards aside let's
not even talk about cards for the next
two minutes let me give you a completely
different perspective
the market is
in such a big bubble today based on few
basic data do you realize in the history
of america
they say around 6 trillion dollars of
money has been printed
of which 20
of it was printed last year
okay let me let me say that one more
time i don't know if you heard what i
just said
go ahead please so
6 20 of all the money
ever printed in us was last year
and now we're doing 1.9 trillion
go don't worry about it just go print it
people are not struggling today
financially it's a seven percent
unemployment we've had
seven percent unemployment so many times
our interest rate is at zero percent
powell said he's going to keep it at
zero until 2023
what does this mean do you realize how
long
interest rates have been below two
percent
it's been two percent since obama took
office in o8
and the only time it went up to two
percent was in trump's second year
after kovit they brought it back down to
zero percent obama kept it between zero
to half a percent for
six years the last
i'm not trying to be negative here
economic expansion was 128 months before
covet hit let me say that one more time
the economy expanded for 128 months
that's 11 years two presidents
three terms that's not that's that's
just
so so you're sitting there and people
say well but but you're just being
pessimistic
no okay so when are cards going to be
fine too
the moment power raises interest rates
get ready for [ __ ] to hit the fan so if
you're buying and selling
do so till the end of 2022 but you
better get ready for 2023 if power
raises interest rates
why here's the interest rates work i
wish i had a pin here to show you
i kind of need the pen to show you this
visual and try to see if i can find this
pen
this is the challenge that a lot of us
are not
uh look when it comes down to marriage
there is
babe i love you you're the best thing
that happened to me yeah
okay babe what's yours what's mine what
do we get married with
hey you have kids when you have kids
there is challenges there's fights
that whole makeup for six hours wedding
you know oh my gosh this greatest
man for this i love you
okay bills taxes health
your parents my parents in-laws
keeping up with fights our fights our
kids fights kids health kids issues
someone dies another funeral another
wedding
that's life so what am i gonna do but i
love her
that's just the beginning you know
marriage is a lot more complicated than
most of us think and when we get married
we don't know what marriage is all about
until you get married then you're like
yeah you know i wish people would have
told me a little bit more about marriage
this is why i say don't get married
until the number starts with three
right so watch this let me show you this
and you see where i'm going with this
interest rates price okay
this is an easy principle that i'm going
to show you okay
here's what's going on today today
prices of everything is very high
because interest rates are zero the
moment they raise it
everything's going to go down prices
that's a house look basic math if you
get a 500
right now today in america if you want
to buy a house the interest rate would
chase bank for 30-year fixes three
percent
you know it's a mortgage payment on a
500 000 loan at three percent
30-year fixed is 2100 okay
do you know what that payment is if
interest rates go to six percent on a
half a million dollar house
three thousand dollars a month you know
what that payment is if a
interest rate goes to nine percent on
that same five hundred thousand dollar
house
four thousand dollars when we buy a
house how do we buy a house do we buy a
house based on interest rate
do we buy a house based on the value of
the house or do we buy a house based on
what we can afford to pay on a monthly
basis
the answer is what what we can afford to
pay on a monthly basis
when some of these events change
postcode
everyone's going to realize that 12 to
24 months of fake money
the price has to be paid for that and my
prediction is it'll be 20 23.
so the next two years a lot of people
are going to look good they're going to
look like oh they know what they're
talking about
but a lot of people are going to look
like idiots in 2023. so brace for impact